well a number of state lawmakers and  legislators they met virtually  and they were talking with business  leaders today with within the chambers  legislative day  so what this event does is highlight  different topics like recovering from  the impacts of the virus  also kind of a status check on how  businesses are coping  senate minority leader james settlemyer  discussed senate bill 323  now that's where businesses can have  designated covid19 areas  if you've had the shot and if you've had  covid  in that other area you can go back to  the way it used to once be  correct to where you could have people  elbow to elbow and then in the  other section people would be having to  obey and utilize  the protocol set forth by the governor  through the emergency directive  we can tell you that that bill has not  had a hearing just yet  other discussions is how corporate  licensing fees increased to 500  making it even harder now for businesses  to make a comeback brian